kerry in lubbock texas carrie how in the
world are you
doing good dr daloni how are you i am
having a blast today
so number one how is my old stomping
grounds is things going okay in lubbock
texas
it's windy and cold it sounds like
business as usual
all right so how can i help you this
morning um me and my husband i've been
married for
20 years okay there's no communication
about our finances and i'm just feeling
very lost and don't know what to do all
right
so my guess is if there's no
communication about finances there's no
communication about much other than
college football is that probably fair
um stock show animals
fair fair for those of y'all not from
west texas we're having some playing
some insider baseball here
um when's the last time y'all had a good
values-based conversation about where
your marriage was going
about kids about who you guys wanted to
be when you grew up
when's the last time y'all had that
conversation or have you ever
we haven't ever he won't
sit down and talk to me and the other
day
i asked him he wanted to do something
and i said you know what i want to do
i want to sit down and have a real
conversation about
our finances and what we need to do we
just recently sold our home
and we moved back up here to where he's
from in
lubbock and um we have this big dream of
building a house and trying to get
everything together
and he tells me he's busy
he doesn't have time and so what is it
about having a conversation that scares
him
i'm not sure i'm not sure and
so let me ask you a harder question what
is it about having a conversation with
you that scares them
um i feel like
he maybe thinks he's failed um out of
the 20 years we've been married
he's only worked eight of those okay
i have my own business and he he has
helped me
but um when we first got married he
worked
all the time when i was going to college
and we had our first daughter
and then it's like he just
quit um he comes to me and
he he he wants something
and i'll tell him no we can't afford
that and he gets upset and mad at me
and tells me i just need to work harder
okay
and then what does he do on on the days
that you're at work did you sit at home
yes did you always have a scheme a plan
i'm just waiting on this phone call to
come in or
this is going to happen soon is it that
kind of situation
no um he's recently started
working and um
so he has been going to work for the
last week
and he's hoping it becomes something
good um
i've always been the bread winner in the
family
um but like my mother-in-law who lives
right next to us
told my daughter when she came down from
college this weekend that
um i made enough money and that my
husband just needed to
stay at home and watch the boys okay is
that an arrangement
you all have that happens all over the
country but usually it's something that
people plan together it doesn't just
inorganically happen or do you not want
to work anymore
um well i mean i'm i'm tired
i do i do a lot i've had my own business
for 15 years
we have four children i do everything
with their
education because he he he was not very
good in school
um but common sense wise i mean he's a
good old farm boy
and he he's really good at outside
things
and but everything else i do and so it's
just
it's just starting to wear on me after
15 years of doing that
and completely basically on my own and i
just
you know i just wish that he would sit
down and talk to me about things instead
of telling me he's busy
or he's got he basically just doesn't
want to carry can i challenge you on
something
i think you've been tired for a long
long time
i think you've been exhausted for a long
long time
and so what i want to know from you is
why now
because you would have been exhausted
i've got two kids and i've got a wife
who is an absolute gangster rock star
and i'm tired
you know what i mean four plus a
full-time gig
plus a husband who's part child too
you've been tired for a long long time
um what has kept you from having that
conversation
for five years ten years
just the fact that i guess i feel
a lot of myself feels ashamed of me
because i feel like i have failed what
did you fail carrie
like our our love for each other is
great but our relationship is not
what does that even mean
um that every morning he tells me he
loves
me and i say i love you too and i always
say i love you
but we have no communication and can't
talk to each other about things
well yeah but i i could wake up i could
wake up with my wife every morning and
say
honey i'm a dragon and she could say i'm
a carton of milk
and that wouldn't make either of those
things real right and so
just going through the motions and
repeating the words doesn't mean much
anything
um
i feel like i get mad and angry yeah
you should get mad and angry you should
be frustrated okay
i do you should be and here's what anger
is
all anger is is a it is a
signal pointing you towards something
that you care about
anger is a good thing
anger lets you know i really care about
this guy
and i need him to go work i need him to
go be a provider for this family or i
need him to be a full-time stay-at-home
dad
and take some of this relational burden
off me some of the
cooking and cleaning and the ceo of the
house roll from me
i desperately need some help and some of
that's about him needing to grow up
and some of that quite honestly is
i'm gonna guess is part of the greater
plague on men across the country which
is they don't know what to do anymore
especially guys who work outside who
have been told
working outside is for idiots for
second-rate losers
that work is getting harder and harder
to come by as the farms get bought up
and as water gets more and more scarce
the whole industry is turning over
and there's a whole swath of guys who
don't know what to do next
and and then there's equally a swath of
women caught right in the middle of that
mess
and so my dream and hope for you carey
is that he would be able to come in and
sit with you
and say listen since i was about
six i've been posturing i've been
playing
and i'm exhausted and i want to love my
wife the right way
and i don't know how can we go learn how
to do this together
i love how esther perel says most adults
have three or four great loves in their
life and if people work really hard and
if they're lucky it's with the same
person
and i believe he can come around but i
also believe he's not going to be the
one who
who has that conversation first
right what i want you to do is to
go spend some time gathering your
thoughts
with probably with a counselor by this
point 15 years of this
is relatively traumatic it's not
relatively
15 years of this is traumatic it's
exhausting
and it's heartbreaking but i believe you
that you still love this dude and i
believe you that when you tell me he's
still worth it
but this is a conversation you got to
have now because here's why
you got four kids you're modeling this
for
you guys and they see it that's right
and more than they see it
carrie they feel it yep they
they actually come to me and that
they're like mom it's okay yeah and
here's the deal
you know kids have no business trying to
make sure their parents are okay
that's not their job right right
it's not their job at the end of the day
all you can control is you
and whether that's by modeling what this
is going to look like which is
honey i'm going to start seeing a
counselor now i would love for you to
come with me
there are some awesome counselors and
marriage therapists in lubbock texas i
know him personally that's where i was
trained
there are some extraordinary people
there in that community that can walk
alongside you
and they can walk alongside your husband
but it's also
about you not waiting till you're
exhausted and frustrated and fed up
before you go have that conversation
because the worst thing you can do to a
guy that's feeling beaten down the guy
that's feeling like he's failed for 10
years
is to run at him when you're angry but
to have a safe place where y'all can
have a good conversation
and here's the other deal carrie the
reality is some guys never get it
some wives never get it either and i
think the hard part for you right now is
you recognize that may be you
it may never come together for you
but all of the wishing and the idol
knows and the imaginary conversations
you have in your head with him
that never happen in real life the
things that you think that he's not
doing these things because of
all of those things are poisoning you
and weighing you down
and they're starting to leak out on your
kids
so can i get a commitment from you that
beginning today you're going to start
taking care of yourself that you'll go
through and find someone to talk to
today make an appointment today before
the day is over
yes okay and i want you to tell him
your husband i love you and we're gonna
schedule a meeting
just a state of the union how's our
marriage how's our kids
how's our future we're going to schedule
a meeting and i want you to plan it for
a week in advance or two weeks in
advance and there are some cooler
breakfast places in lubbock texas
and i want you to plan it for a place
where y'all can get up on a saturday
morning and go talk to one another
and i want you to have a list of things
written out
and i want you to make sure he knows
he's loved i want you to make sure that
he knows
that he's valued but i also want him to
know that you're exhausted
and that you are interested in
completely rebuilding your relationship
from the floor up
but it's going to take his full
participation in that
and guys if you're listening to this is
never too late
to go talk to your wife
it is never too late to go talk to your
girlfriend to someone you're interested
in to any significant other to your
parents to your friends it's never too
late guys
to go in there and say
it's been five years it's been 10 years
and i don't like with the direct
trajectory of where i'm going
i don't like it i want to start over can
we rebuild this thing up from the floor
up and i'm going to need some
lessons i'm going to need to learn how
to do this i don't even know what i feel
anymore
i'm going to go back to community
college i'm going to need to go
fill in the blanks guys it's never too
late to have that conversation
women it's never too late to have that
conversation either
you don't need to wait till new year's
eve you can start today
start today but set up some time to go
have that conversation
and start taking care of you carrie
after that conversation i want you to
call me back i want you to let me know
how it goes
and if you need some some folks in that
area that i trust
um get with kelly and then i will
connect you to somebody that
some folks that i know and love and
trust there in that community we'll be
thinking about you carey
and get to work on you get to work on
you
and get to work on that marriage